في نورك كارولين في امريكا في سيده اسمها
كينيس لون تستحق عن جداره لقب السيد
الاكثر حظا في العالم
ربحت في اغسطس الماضي جائزه يانصيب قيمتها
مليون دولار لكن هذا لحاله مش راح يكون
سبب منح لقب الامراض الامراه الاكثر حظا
فبعدنا فازت بمليون دولار بشهرين بس السيد
رجعت فازت بجائزه يا نصيب ثانيه وهاي
المره الجائزه قيمتها مليونين دولار
متخيلين ثلاث ملايين دولار في ظرف شهرين
يعني الله يكمل يكملها بعقلها للسيدات
واللي بيزيد اكثر واكثر انها كشفت انه
الجائزتين المنفصلتين كانت اول مره
بحياتها بتشارك فيهم لما فازت هذا الحجر
الصراحه زي ما بنقول الست كشفت انه هي
بنفسها مش مصدقه اللي معها ولا حتى
قرايبها واصحابها مصدقين بطاقه ال 10
دولارات ربحتها مليون وبطاقه ال20 دولار
ربحتها مليونين اما كيف ناويه تصرف
الملايين فكشفت انه بعد الجائزه الاولى
بدات تعمر بيت احلامها وقربت تخلصوا الان
وقالت انها صار لها 15 سنه بتحلم انها
تمتلك منزل والمليون دولار الاولى هذا
الحلم اما الجائز الجديده فناويه تفتح
فيها مطعم